le brouillard s'était invité pour cette
deuxième édition post covid de parcourir
Montigny organisé par le Stadium
Montigny Athletic Club ses courses de 5
et 10 km permettaient aux participants
de s'élancer à travers le quartier du
village créé en 1984 comme un parcours
loisir cette course a depuis été
labellisée au niveau régional par la
Fédération Française d'Athlétisme les
courses à la belle permettent aux gens
qui font un chrono de pouvoir se
qualifier pour les championnats de
France et l'intéressant c'est que elle
emprunte des le vieux villages là qui
est la naissance de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et puis l'avenue
Nicolas Abou qui est aussi un personnage
qui a été important dans la dans
l'évolution de la ville donc c'est un
peu un parcours dans l'histoire entre la
création et puis et la ville nouvelle
quoi ce parcours présenté 30 mètres de
dénivelé avec peu de virages cette inhy
montagne avait déjà participé à
l'édition précédente son but ce dimanche
13 novembre battre son propre record de
45 minutes je vais pas partir trop vite
parce que c'est souvent le défaut de
partir trop vite et d'être cramé ce qui
a quand même 10 km donc essayer d'avoir
une allure régulière je vais essayer de
me caler sur du 4 entre 4,25 430 on va
voir comment ça va être et si j'ai du
juge accélère à la fin d'autres
participants étaient venus simplement se
remettre en scène le niveau ça sera un
petit niveau moyen niveau très moyen là
je me mets objectif aller 28 minutes une
fois la ligne d'arrivée passée sabbat ne
cachait pas sa joie d'avoir terminé
neuvième féminine la cour aux serroises
avait déjà participé à l'édition
précédente j'avais fait 46 minutes donc
aujourd'hui je suis contente 43 minutes
donc 3 minutes de gagner sur l'année
dernière donc je suis très contente le
parcours était difficile avec plusieurs
faux plats montants le premier coureur
des 10 km à franchi la ligne d'arrivée
en 32 minutes et une seconde pour la
course des 5 km alien Mehdi a décroché
la première place avec 15 minutes et 40
secondes
environ 1000 coureurs ont bravé le froid
pour participer à cette nouvelle édition
de parcourir Montigny